good evening and welcome to this meeting
of the development committee I will now
read out the emergency evacuation
announcement
there are no planned fire drills so if
the alarm
goes off please leave the building in
orderly fashion through the nearest fire
exit
please use either the Firex sit through
the main doors or the hall or the fire
exit in the storeroom adjacent to the
stage
the fire assembly point is in the island
in front of the main entrance of the
building
please do not delay your delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff
please note that the meeting will be
audio recorded
please switch off phones that or turn
them to silent please note the toilet
and hand washing facilities are in the
foyer area
members of the public are reminded that
this is an official council meeting and
the items before us will be debated
according to the usual Council rules for
Council meetings which to which the
public are omitted members of the public
are not permitted to speak at this
meeting unless they have previously
registered to speak with Democratic
services
in this way everyone present will be
able to hear
the debate and counselors will be able
to make an informed decision
can I also asks
can I please also remind you to be
respectful of all the of all those
attending the meeting including other
members of the public counselors and
officers
members of public while you're here of
course entitled to film or tape
photographs during this meeting can I
please emphasize to you that this should
be done without disruption to the
meeting and can only be done from a
designated area
in in the public seating can I please
therefore ask you to raise your hand
clearly in the air if you wish to take
photographs or film this evening
no no anyone else no thank you there is
no one
members there is a need to use
microphones during the meeting when I
invite you to speak please wait until
there is a microphone in front of you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing Loop and for the
audio recording
these are all switched on and are ready
for you to speak and will be unmuted by
offices for you
please make sure that the microphone
please make sure that the microphone is
directly in front of your mouth before
speaking members voting will be done on
a show of hands in lie with the
Constitution I would ask for a show of
hands for and then against
recommendations and would also ask for a
show of hands for those wishing to
abstain from voting
agenda item 102 apologies for absence
any substitute members
who have received apologies for absence
from councilor Stuart Wilson and I
think Council of Hawaii will be subdune
for councilor night and councilor
landlord will be substitute shooting for
councilor Wilson sorry I didn't realize
that
non-members attending we have councilor
McPherson
Council across and I've got the hand I
can't see counselor councilor James
Newport
have I missed anyone because who I can't
see
no thank you
minutes of the meeting held on the 28th
of February 2023 are these minutes
agreed members
agreed thank you
item five to receive Declarations of
Interest
has anyone got any interest decorations
of Interest
none
item six then we're doing 19 stroke zero
zero zeros 734 full learned opposite to
one to ten Disraeli Road
[Music]
will be talking us through this thank
you Claire
so this application is through erector
stable block comprising three individual
stables and lay hard standing at the
site known as land opposite one to ten
Disraeli Road Rayleigh as you can see on
the site here
so the application site is situated on
the Northern side of Disraeli Road
Israeli Road running along this side
here
Society situated in the Green Mill and
is vacant from development apart from
some children's play equipment to the
north of the site is open and wooded
land so that's just here and then to the
east
um of the site is wooded land as well to
the West is a stable development and to
the south of the residential dwellings
one to 10 Israeli road so you can see
those dwellings along here
yeah plan two please oh thank you Katie
The Proposal is to construct a stable
development and hard standing to the
Southeastern corner of the site with the
three stable doors facing west if
possible can you zoom in just a little
bit on that beat Katie for me please
thank you so this is where the stable
development be in this corner of the
site and as you can see the access will
be here this will be where the hardest
standing would be and this is a stable
block here
we could have plan three please thank
you
as you can see from the elevations The
Proposal would have the standard
appearance of a small stable development
using black Timber cladding and
red-facing Bricks
as you can see standard sort of stable
type development in in design just at
the bottom here with the elevations
as explained within the addendum members
should be made aware that this
application has already been before
development committee on the 21st
November 2019 it was referred from the
weekly list on grounds of harm to the
green belt and they're being
insufficient land available to support
the horse and ponies that would use the
site
members were money to approve this
application at the 2019 development
committee meeting with three conditions
attached but also subject to the
applicant entering into a section 106
legal agreement preventing the use of
the stay with development for any other
purpose and requiring its removal if the
building and land is no longer required
for the approved use
since this time there has been no
attempt by the applicant to enter into a
legal agreement therefore this
application which requires a decision to
be issued by the council has been left
undetermined since 2019.
in bringing this application back before
members officers are looking to resolve
this issue and reach a point whereby a
decision can finally be issued here
the circumstances surrounding the
application remain the same so the
proposal is still for one horse and two
ponies to graze the land and use the
stables and the applicant still has
access to the land of neighboring
properties for grazing there has also
been no change in policy since this
application was last considered at
Development Committee it therefore
remains officer's view that the proposal
is acceptable it would not be harmful to
the green belt it Remains the case at
sufficient grazing land is available to
care for the horse and ponies with
access to other neighboring land and
there is not considered to be a
detrimental impact on residential
amenity or the highway
it should be noted that there have been
a number of applications for stable
development approved within the district
since 2019 none of which have been
subject to a section 106 legal agreement
so a condition at the Disraeli Road Site
controlling the use as opposed to a
section 106 would be consistent with how
the council have approached other
decisions
this application is recommended for
approval subject to the conditions
outlined in the regional officers report
but also with the inclusion of a further
condition number four as stated within
the addendum to the officer's report
controlling the use of the building and
its removal if the use of the land or
building ceases in place of the
initially agreed section 106 legal
agreement thank you
no public speakers for this item
but we do have councilor Mr Newport do
you need would you like to speak on this
please
because you're the wall counselor
Stanley
so I've got you as well counselor
McPherson would you like to speak on
this item
no but we cannot we have to ask if you
want Council cross do you need to speak
on this item thank you right we now have
go to
council Crips
well
right this is going very well isn't it
counselor Milne
uh we're working good
um yeah I originally called this in
because it was on the the area of
grazing land
and I know I noticed that there is a
excuse me the mill can you speak
up okay I originally called this in
because of the area of grazing land was
insufficient
and and also the this issue with the
green belt but
I don't really see that it's really
changed much although there is a link to
a website
which implies that it could just about
meet the minimum standard
so from my point of view I don't really
see that very much has changed really
and that that's really my point of view
thank you have you any questions for our
officers councilman uh no they've
explored the the issues and at this time
they're recommending an approval but
then the way I'm looking at it I don't
see that argument has changed much thank
you very much
the Claire would you like to come back
on this please
I just wanted to clarify we did
recommend
um approval previous time around as well
so it's just we're bringing it back to
committee because whilst members also
reminded to approve we didn't get to a
point where we could actually issue the
decision on this application because it
needed a legal agreement to be signed
and entered into by the applicant so
what we're bringing back to members now
is a way to try and resolve that and get
this decision issued by rather than
entering into a legal agreement by
controlling that by condition instead so
it's there's no change the application
in terms of officers perspective with
the recommendation it's just looking to
be able to issue a decision
um just with a condition rather than a
legal agreement on here
members doesn't
cancer are you a mem will member
would you like to speak please
who are we going
yeah right no I would just like to work
through
can you speak to the mic please thank
you I'd like to Echo what councilor
Milne said
um
from the previous application nothing
really seems to have changed I'm
concerned about
anything that gets built on Greenbelt
but um
so
and also does this then give them rights
to then convert that stable to a to
another property at a later date
right
so that's really part of the basis of us
bringing it back to committee so members
remind you to approve it last time round
but with a control by legal agreement
around the usage of that building and to
ensure that it doesn't get converted to
another person in the future so it had a
it was approved by members subject to
the applicant entering into a legal
agreement so the building itself would
need to be removed if it was no longer
used for the purpose to which we're
approving it today or it was been
approved previously sorry
um and if the land itself
um also ceased to be used for an
equestrian use so what we're bringing
back to members today is rather than
actually controlling that usage by legal
agreement controlling it by condition
planning condition instead
if you
don't if you say everything what you've
just asked
so
okay so hopefully members I've got
councilor guidance and councilor Stanley
Council and Council Fosters councilor
godson please
I'd like to ask Claire the officer why
is Noah League the applicant not come
forward to sign a legal or s106
agreement
but
sorry it's not clear to be honest um
we don't know we did ask that question
and we have queried about entering into
a legal agreement in these earlier
stages of members mining for it to be
approved in 2019
um but it just wasn't forthcoming so I'm
not entirely sure for the reasoning
behind that so this application has it
been submitted by the um resubmitted by
the council to get it cleared or as the
applicant put the application in the
game
so no it's officers bring it back to
council it's not the applicant I did
think that I just want you to check that
also I've got a concern regarding the
actual size of the plot it's under the
recommended size for keeping the amount
of animals there I just wondered why
it's now acceptable when it's under the
legal guidelines
so the the grazing land query was looked
at the last time around
um and that was part of the reason it
was referred to committee now officer's
perspective is that our policy requires
a minimum of 0.5 hectare
um per horse but the whole society
standards also have a caveat to them
um whereby if a horse requires less
grazing land or if maybe for example
it's a pony that requires less and we
can potentially accept a lesser Quantum
now at this particular site as well
whilst the site area itself is 0.31
hectare
um it's actually the case that the
applicant has access to other land and
neighboring the site and slightly
further down as well and we are aware
that that situation remains and so
actually that brings that up to 1.21
hectare which is just over the 1.2 that
we would need policy wise so although
that's not within their entire ownership
it's also land they have access to which
would bring it within the policy and to
say we did that was visited before and
members were mining to approve the the
grazing land situation on the site
previously
um
I part of my concern is that the grazing
land there's no formal contract so my
understanding of that is that if the
landowner decided to withdraw that
then the applicant would be in a
position of having to take down the
Stables is that right
so if any Arrangement that they have
independently with a neighbor for
example
um would result in a lesser Quantum of
land it
it wouldn't require the building to be
removed at that point the building would
need to be removed if the land which
this is subject directly of the red line
bound on this application if that cease
to be used and for question and purposes
and the building itself it will be at
that point yeah okay thank you for sure
thank you
thank you thank you chairman
um part of my question has already been
uh answered previously by the councilor
Mrs Gladstone
um
in respect of that land may be withdrawn
it wouldn't be sufficient to house the
three horses or two parties on one horse
um
would it therefore mean that
we that the applicant could reduce his
livestock to accommodate that land or
would that actually
would it come into foster if the land
was smaller than what it originally is
now that that would actually go back to
green belt land
also I did notice that
um we've got a little item in that 1.94
um
in saying that it's if it is no longer
available for grazing of horses
occupying The Stables here by approved a
stable building must be removed
it says for grazing and not that the
land is if the land is smaller than what
the applicant has already got and I
would like to put that in the condition
that if it is smaller and not able to
graze
then the stable blocks will be removed
if that's possible chairman thank you
would you like to come back of that
please yes so
it's right to say that at the moment we
are considering land
um in terms of assessing this
application which is also outside the
boundary in terms of
um access
but with regards to this application as
well irrespective of the usage of that
land it's also a consideration as to the
fact that there are two ponies using the
land as well as horses and ponies do
require a lesser Quantum of spacing than
horses do so that's also a factor to put
in the mix in terms of the overall
grazing land
um necessity to support this site
and I don't think it would be reasonable
for us to control by condition
um the need to cease this use if access
to those neighboring lands become
um unavailable because of the fact that
they are outside of this red line site
boundary and they are not land either
that would be normally identified as
blue I.E within the own within the
applicant's control either so I don't
see that that's something that we can
control as part of this application
[Music]
thank you chairman
um it's been touched upon a little bit a
simple question is a condition more
difficult to enforce than a legal
agreement
so
so a condition
um
a legal agreement has more I suppose
legal implications in the sense that um
someone would have or it would be our
legal team to then sort of enforce that
when it comes to a breach of a condition
if someone breached a condition it would
then be for our planning enforcement
team to consider and assess um the
impact of that and issue and a breaching
condition notice if we were unhappy with
the breach that was take off we thought
the breach was taking place was unlike
skip planning permission
um so it's it's just a different process
really a different form of control
and something in legal Agreements are
more commonly used and our planning
practice guidance advises us to use them
in much more major type developments
where you're looking to control more
commonly Financial things such as
affordable housing requirements
education monies NHS monies it's not
common for them to be used
um in this kind of level of scheme and
where conditions can suffice
I'm
I can't quite understand why we've gone
from a legal agreement
to a condition
why wouldn't he
applicant want a legal agreement
not be happy with the condition I say
they don't quite get it the reason maybe
and it's also relevant to us there is a
cost implication in actually entering
into a legal agreement so they would
have to employ a solicitor to produce a
legal agreement for them we would have
to use our solicitors to also work and
produce that legal agreement and get it
signed whereas a planning condition is
just something that we impose on the
decision notices and gets issued to it's
not got cost implication involved for
applicant or Council in its production
so that may be that may be the reason
behind it
are there any other members councilor
Crips and councilor FD so Council Crips
please
thank you
um the 1.94 very definitive condition
I just want to clarify one thing
it says
if the land Edge read
on the drawing number so and so is no
longer available for grazing of horses
it moves on to say that
the land we returned to its original
case The Stables would be gone and so on
there's the land is the land for the
horse is quite tenuous there appears to
be a potential civil matter
uh in terms of ownership in one
particular area and I think it relies on
two other parties to create that Speck
of land so
are we happy that this is definitive
enough if one of those Parcels of land
goes missing from within the red area it
then Falls below the minimum requirement
to support the horses that's it that's
when it's got to be cleared because that
thing that lands no long is that a right
interpretation of it
um new enough um Katie can you zoom out
slightly and I can just explain some of
the land a little bit more please thank
you
so at the moment
um gosh I might need the location plans
please Katie I'm not sure what shows at
all thank you
and
so the minute the red line boundaries
here
now we are aware that they have access
to this site here and some land here and
some land slightly further up which is
opposite number one and two which I
think is this sort of parcel here
um or it might be this one so Constance
were zoomed out a bit too much
um but the condition would look and
would control this red lined area here
so if the use of that specific area of
land and the Stables within that were
deceased that is when the building would
need to be removed from the site it
wouldn't if if the arrangement with the
neighboring land
um were to cease it wouldn't require the
removal of the building
but that was the same conclusion should
we say that was reached previously when
then this reminded to
just clarification I'm sorry but does
that mean the amount of land available
be it on site or off-site is now below
the required amount
so if that
were to Cease the use of the neighboring
land then they would be down to the 0.31
hectare in total for one horse and two
ponies so it would be below the 0.4
hectare requirement per horse but as
explained the British org Society
standards does give us leniency to
consider other situations and
circumstances such as ponies requiring a
lesser Quantum anyway
foreign
thank you
um
I'm a little bit concerned with the 106
and conditions this was
put through in 2019
they had to come assign a 106 agreement
so it's been 19
2013 free four years and they've not
come forward to sign the 106. and this
is just to clear our books through
either to agree or not to agree it
106 is a legal agreement the conditions
we have to impose so I'm
I'm more inclined to
can't really support this because I'd
much rather see a 106 agreement than any
condition
thank you
oh sorry
was there any other member that wishes
to speak
nope I have a motion uh
to approve this application subject to
conditions one through to three set out
on pages 6.12 of the report and the
additional condition for set out on
pages
6.15 of the report
can I have a oh I got a second to please
counselors debusha thank you
members in favor of approval can I
please have a show of hands
members you can lower your hands thank
you members for refusal
placed against the application against
the approval sorry misuse of words
thank you members you can allow any
abstentions members
three
right members it is five four five
against
for abstention three extensions sorry
Sonia couldn't be writing so I've got
the casting vote and I'll vote as I've
just done I will approve this
application thank you members
so that is carried thank you a gender
item seven
yeah yeah
I agenda item 722 stroke
zero one one one four four Thirty One
Barney Road great way cream Katie Fowler
will present the officer report
thank you chairman
uh so this application came before
members at the last committee and we
deferred it for a site visit which took
place at the weekend so
um just to provide a bit of context to
the application as I appreciate there's
a lot of history to it so
um this dwelling on screen was the
dwelling that was demolished on site
um and was subsequently granted planning
permission in 2020 to rebuild it like
for like so this existed previously and
then was granted permission to rebuild
it exactly as it appears now on the
screen
um this forms a full back position to
the application where planning
permission refused the applicant would
have to build out in accordance with
that dwelling that you see and this was
a part of the appeal decision the
inspector acquired the modification of
the dwelling that's been built on site
to rebuild the dwelling exactly the same
as that one that you see on the screen
if you could go to the second tab please
clear thanks
um so this dwelling that you see here is
the dwelling that exists on the site at
present
um so the dwelling has been built
unlawfully and the part that we are
concerned with today is this dwelling so
the outbuildings this link and the
single story extensions would be removed
and then this dwelling would be reduced
in height
so
um its retention was dismissed at
appealed by the inspector so that
required it to be removed or modified to
rebuild as that previous picture that I
just showed you
um if you could go to the third tab
please Claire
sorry you might have to zoom out now if
you go to the three circles at the top
right hand corner yeah we have to zoom
out that way for some reason
thank you
and so this image shows the differences
between the on-site dwelling and that
proposed so you should see here the
ridge height is decreased so the blue
here which goes higher is the dwelling
which is on site and then the red or
orangey color is the what's now proposed
and you'll see that also the single
story extensions uh were also removed
um the inspects the inspector's decision
had ish had required that the ridge
height be reduced
um and the inspector noted that the
inclusion of a third floor
um which increased the ridge height
would be
would mean that rooms in the roof
sorry let me start that one again
um so the inclusion of the third floor
as part of the inspector's decision was
considered inappropriate and the the
decrease of the ridge height means that
the third floor wouldn't be able to be
used as it is presently
um because of the decrease in height it
means that the eaves High and the room
height wouldn't be uh as substantial as
it is at present
um so the inspector took issue with this
but we believe that this has been
overcome as part of the proposal and
officers are comfortable that the
proposal would overcome any concerns
that were raised by the inspector within
the appeal for the unlawful dwelling
um Claire if you could just scroll down
to the second image so you can see that
just from the ground floor the
difference between
um these single story elements being
removed and then there are what would
remain on site so that has reflected the
decrease in floor space as well if you
could go to the fifth tab sorry Claire
I've not put them in the right order the
next one along
thank you
um so
this plan was submitted with as part of
the application to show the differences
in floor space between the what's now
proposed and what previously existed on
the site so that first image that I
showed you
um so the if you could just scroll down
slightly clear
the the bottom plan reflects on the left
hand side the proposed ground floor and
the right hand side is what they would
have to build if this application were
refused so you can see that the floor
space has kind of been accumulated in
into one kind of footprint as before it
sprawled over a greater area
so our view is that the proposal would
not be materially larger than the
demolished dwelling and would be
considered acceptable
and so although it's larger in some
instances if you could just scroll up a
little bit on that one Claire yeah
um overall it has been condensed into a
smaller footprint and so that's where we
have come to The View on that one uh if
you go to the fourth tab now where it
says graphs thank you
um so this graph was included in the
officer report and you can see that
we've laid out the demolished or
approved dwelling however you would like
to refer to it there are a few so this
was refused planning permission the
on-site as these both varied slightly
but it's essentially what exists on site
now and then what is proposed as part of
this application
um so they show the differences between
the floor plans of the various
applications and it shows that the floor
space that the proposed dwelling is more
comparable to that of the demolished
dwelling rather than those that that was
um considered at the appeal and the
refused dwelling is far larger in floor
space than that of the proposed dwelling
if you could go to the one that says
elevation to the yeah thank you
so this comparison shows the difference
between the proposed dwelling and that
which was demolished so the image that
was shown at the start of the
presentation you can see that the ridge
height and massing of the proposed
dwelling would be comparable the kind of
different colors are barely kind of
distinguishable between
um them on the front elevation if you
just like to scroll down clear you can
see it from the side elevation so you
can see the ridge Heights are comparable
as well as the massing although it's
greater in some areas it's also reduced
in other areas so overall it
um kind of accumulates to something that
is comparable to one another
um obvious conclusion is that the impact
the proposed dwelling would not be
materially larger than the demolished
dwelling or would not be considered to
have a greater impact in the green belt
where the application submitted now and
we were considering whether the
demolished dwelling
um was materially larger than that is
now proposed we would be recommending
the application for approval so
um that's where we would stand now if
you could just go back to the graph
Claire on the second page if you scroll
down
uh we have a similar table comparing the
demolished dwelling the refused on-site
appeal ones and then what's now proposed
and you can see that the measurements of
the demolished and proposed are
particularly comparable
um okay if you could go to 100 and a
thank you and so on the addendum for the
January committee it addressed an
additional condition which restricted
the area hatched to be the only area
used as residential Garden
the condition also removed preventive
development rights in relation to
outbuildings Across the entire site
the addendum amended condition 2 to
substitute the location plan which has
been hatched and the conditions relating
to materials Landscaping OBS Windows
permitted development rights of
extensions to the dwellings were
included in the officer's report
it is noted that condition one will need
to be amended to reflect the new
enforcement time frame of the 15th of
December 2023 and the condition would
require the development to have been
begun prior to this day Claire if you
could just click on the word document
tab at the bottom you might have to drag
it onto that screen
so I've just highlighted the oh
thanks so I've just highlighted the
changes um to the conditions just to
clearly set them out so the first
condition would be changed so that it
reads as the 15th of December 2023.
it's okay we can just scroll down Claire
and then the second condition is amended
to reflect that revised location plan
which allowed us to condition the
residential garden and removing
repayments development rights for
outbuildings if you could scroll down
Claire three and four remain the same if
you could keep scrolling
five and six remain the same and then
seven is the additional condition which
restricts the Garden area
and no outbuildings in either the red
line site or the blue line site
the application is therefore recommended
for approval chairman subject to the
conditions set out within the officer
report the addendum to the general
committee and the amendment to condition
one reflecting the variation of the
enforcement deadline thank you
thank you very much Claire we have once
uh
no public speakers but we have
councilman McPherson who's one of the
wall councilors
we've now changed council at first and
you're not speaking up there it's not
now we're back on the corner
yeah thank you you have a mic and it
looks like it's on thank you you have
five minutes person thank you
thank you chairman
um first of all thank you to all the
members who attended the site visit on
Saturday
I gather from the chatter it opened more
questions for you as before I will try
to speak clearly quickly and refer to
pages and paragraphs within the
application
so page 7.5 3.3 relevant planning
history officers say and there has been
extensive site history that doesn't
really cut it it was five or six
applications to demolish the existing
house all were refused
however the planner owner or agent as
someone made the decision decided to
ignore planning
tore down the existing house
and if you can go to that's the one and
zoom in on that please
tore down the existing house not only
the house but as you can see every
single tree
as I mentioned before when I spoke on
this item it wasn't called Orchard house
for nothing
and now there are no trees the wildlife
were also affected all of this was done
without permission
so again members when we do have
campaigners fighting for one tree don't
forget this goes on in your District
unlawfully
of course officers will remind you that
the application
that is the application that is in front
of you tonight not the surrounding also
unlawful buildings that the applicant
has put up
unlawful
Ponder on that word the definition in
the Great British Oxford dictionary says
unlawful means illegal law breaking
against the law Criminal
I don't know about you but tearing down
those trees decimating Wildlife
habitation yes it's pretty criminal to
me
moving forward retrospectively an
application was made in 2020 which the
officer has just referred to this was a
like for like
home as the house that had sat there
before you
far smaller than the one that is in
front of you tonight
conditions of the approved application
in June 2020 included the replanting of
the trees
it had further conditions that if they
should have died or been serious
seriously damaged within five years of
planting shall be replaced by the the
developer or their successes perhaps
members should you be mindful to prove
this you might want to add that to be
infinited
so that they are always there under
informatives on the application in June
2020 just for your reference the
applicant should also be made aware that
departure from the approved plan is
likely to result in the development
being unauthorized with the requirement
of further application
and this is where we are now
strongly
advised they were that minor changes May
likely require new application so not
content we're finally getting approval
in 2020 which I think must be nearing
its expiry date I believe would then
need to come back to committee
you have a bigger
development in front of you all bite
officers will say not considerable
although you may think
that another floor on top of the
accommodation is
so members it's down to you you have the
advice given by the inspector at the
appeal upholding our council's decision
referred to as page 7.4 2.6
members I would query where you stand on
this as referring to page 7.4
it was the inspector that ruled the date
of the 18th of March 2020
and as the officers pointed out this has
passed
he is also the recommendation thank you
it is also the recommendation on 7.1 are
you voting on a lawful paper
however you vote members post this
application I would like to see a
thorough review one perhaps for you
members
to recommend here tonight as I for one
One open season in our district stopped
our Builders agents and Property Owners
taking the eversa proverbial Michael or
do they just know the loopholes which
are best to get what they want is the
law weighed on their side whoever and
for whatever reason it is that people
think they can do this it now has to
stop this Council needs to put on their
big boy pants
these selfish bullish attitude and
protect our Green Belt wildlife and
environment thank you gentlemen
the other world member is Council FD I'm
just Consulting with him he is not going
to speak on this have we got any other
members of this committee that
oh sorry I just realized I was indicated
by everyone dumb she would like to say
something
foreign
just just to remind members
um that tonight
um you are voting on the application
that's before you and it should only be
material planning considerations that
you take into consideration tonight
um the removal of the trees in the
garden are not a material planning
consideration before you for this
application neither is the enforcement
history on the site you have to make
your decision based on what's being
presented before you so just a polite
reminder and no disrespect to councilman
McPherson
any comments
no well they're members if there's no
one wants to speak there is a motion for
approval the recommendation is to prove
the application subject to conditions
one through to seven
set out on pages 7.1 to 7.3 or through
pool and subject to revised condition
two and the additional condition set out
on page 7.23 of the report
have I have taken uh I will move this
has I got a second on this please
oh sorry and I've just been notified
because I haven't got that on there and
so
yeah
and amendment to condition one two
three left for free reflect the time
okay members
so
um of motion for I'll put through the
forward emotion how about a second a
place councilor godson
members can I have a show of hands in
favor of to approve this application
thank you members members can I have a
show of hands full refusal of this
application
any thank you members any abstentions
members
members there's eight four
three against two of the sanctions this
as approval has been carried thank you
members on item eight has everyone got
the addendum
please before we start and they're both
of course you can
do you want to fight does anybody want a
five minute break right I'll give a five
minute break I'd like everyone back at
25 past thank you
it's
um
uh but the job is we get tall ground and
they get 35.
so I get 24. I want more than seven
yeah
so I'm actually on more than silent
which is wrong
for what he any leader sorry but then
you're covering the bigger area I've got
182 million
National
geographical
the budget and the number of residence
we've got a bit nearly a billion money
I was just asking what she was what she
was on about what each of the sky was
the enforcement yeah
why it took so long to be enforced
when he was putting the trees I do
believe I do believe that the appeal
I think Katie did take one
she put a bit of a wrong and report in
so I've heard but I don't know the full
story and I've gone on
right
thank you very much
one
what we do now
might be all back
right members I'll restart the meeting
please
a gender item eight 23 Strokes zero zero
zero twelve out 270 Eastwood Road
Rayleigh and it's Katie Fowler that we
will present tonight's report thank you
Katie thank you chairman so the
application site is located on the south
side of Eastwood Road and to the east of
South View close so it is just this kind
of square here oh sorry
there we go goes around here and then up
including this dwelling that fronts at
Eastford Road the site is commonly
occupied by domestic nursery and a
stream which runs east to west through
the site the site is largely adjoined by
land which is used to agricultural
nursery and other light industrial
purposes with the exceptions of the
dwellings on Eastwood Road and South
View close
okay if you could just go to the flood
zone plan
thank you so the application site is
located within the green belt but it's
also in a section a section of the site
is within flood zones two and three so
this darker blue that runs through the
middle is flood zone three and then the
lighter blue is flood zone two with the
vast majority of the site located within
flood zones one
and members will be familiar with the
site as a previous application came
before the committee in August last year
the application was for the construction
of a 70 bed Care Home 35 affordable
homes and 30 lifetime homes the
application was refused for reasons
relating to Greenbelt impact of noise on
adjoining residents and the impact of
the X the access upon the TPO Tree on
Eastwood Road
if you could go to the indicative layout
please
thank you the proposal now put forward
is for a 60 bed care home and 35 later
living homes and so on the right hand
side you can see this is the care home
and then the 35 later living homes and
they are all north of this stream which
runs east to west
the application is for outline
permission with all that matters
reserved except for Access and the
development has been shown with an
access from Eastwood Road
the application has not been considered
to meet any of the exceptions for
development within the Greenville under
paragraph 149 or 150 of the mppf in this
regard the development can be considered
as inappropriate development within the
green belt which is harmful by
definition
Hamid also result to the spatial and
visual impact on openness that would
constitute urban sprawl in the green
belt on this basis it must be
demonstrated that there are very special
circumstances which exist that clearly
outweigh the harm identified and any
other harm
the very special circumstances put
forward by the applicant is the need for
older persons accommodation within the
district
this has been considered from both the
proposed communal accommodation and
later living bungalows the officer
report concludes that there is no
short-term unmet need for communal
accommodation and no compelling evidence
to demonstrate that any long-term unmet
need for additional communal
accommodation could not be accommodated
outside of the green belt the breakdown
of what form of older person's
accommodation the later living Bungalows
would provide has not been stated and it
is assumed that they would be
age-restricted Market homes
it is considered that the council are
able to provide some form of
accommodation for older people through
the requirements to deliver on
accessible and adaptable housing on
larger housing schemes by policy 86 of
the core strategy this is therefore only
attributed at best moderate weight but
the test within the mppf requires
substantial weight to be attached to
Greenbelt harm and so the proposal would
not be clearly outweighed
further to composing the officer's
report the agent has submitted an older
person's need assessment which they had
independently produced this assessment
under identifies a far different need
than that of the councils and given its
late submission officers have not had
time to gain the views of the
Consultants who prepared our needs
assessment this has been discussed
within the addendum and is on this basis
that the recommendation has been amended
to a deferment to allow for officers to
come competently consider this
information
an access is not a matter reserved and
it is for consideration at outline stage
the access would be created by
demolishing 270 Eastwood Road which you
can see the access plan here
and would therefore provide access and
egress to the site from Eastwood Road
as part of the construction of this
access the bus stop outside of 270 Road
270 Eastwood Road would need to be
relocated so at present it's
approximately just in front of 270
Eastwood Road and it would need to be
located sorry Claire if you could go
back to the location plan it's probably
easier to show on there
so the bus stop is just kind of this dip
in the road in front of 270 Eastwood
Road and it would be located east of the
sorry west of the application site past
the lay-by which fronts the dwellings on
Eastwood Road
this has been a great in principle by
Essex County Council for the relocation
to the west of the site the lay-by to
the front of the properties along
Eastwood Road would not be impacted at
the bus stop would be on a carriageway
as it would be a carriageway bus stop
this is to help promote sustainable
transport options by prioritizing bus
movements rather than other vehicular
movements
it is acknowledged that bus route 20
turns right up Clarence Road meaning
they would not function with the
relocated bus stop so Clarence Road is
just this road here and at present the
bus 20 stops here and then turns right
up Clarence Road
however there is an existing stop so 186
meters east of the site which would
serve people using bus route 20. the
distance between the bus stop outside of
the application stop at site and the bus
stop to the east would not be
unreasonable and would still be
compliant with the distances between bus
stops that is required by Essex County
Council
the access would also be provided with a
sufficient visibility display that would
not be impeded by Street trees or the
lay-by on Eastwood Road on this basis no
objection has been raised with regard to
the impact of The Proposal upon highway
safety
whilst there was a previous objection
relating to the impact of the access
upon adjoining neighbors this concern
has been overcome as part of this
resubmitted application with the
previous application the council's
environmental health officer at the time
was consulted on the application
whilst he raised no objection to the
application this was subject to two
conditions however officers did not feel
that these conditions complied with the
six tests required for a condition to be
imposed on this basis officers could not
be content that there would not be an
unacceptable impact of noise
however the counts were Now using a new
environmental health officer to provide
responses on applications this officer
was able to recommend conditions which
did meet those six tests necessary on
this basis the eha was confident that
the impact of noise could be dealt with
by condition and at a reserved matter
stage the concern relating to noise has
therefore been overcome and no longer
forms a reason for refusal other matters
of consideration relating to the impact
on residents would be for determination
at a reserved matter stage
as shown at start part of the
application site is located within flood
since two and three and this covers land
either side of the stream which runs
east to west
however the development has been
indicatively shown on the northern part
of land within flood zone 1. just for
reference it would be this parcel here
and we're planning permission granted it
could be conditioned to ensure the
development was sequentially cited in
this location
irrespective of its location within the
flood zone as the development is Major
it was required to provide a flood risk
assessment and drainage strategy the
officer's report included a reason for
refusal relating to the absence of a
flood risk assessment and drainage
strategy once published last week the
agent provided the fra and was that was
submitted for the previous scheme this
has been sent to the EA and the lead
local flood Authority for their comments
the EA raised no objection however the
llfa have a raised a couple of questions
which have been sent over to the agent
these points are still outstanding for
consideration
whilst this did not amount to a reason
for refusal previously flood risk policy
has since been updated within the mppg
the addendum has updated members on this
matter and objection is currently raised
to the insufficient information to allow
for consideration of the fra by officers
and consultees
the orchard nearby Woodland and stream
have been identified as habitats for
protected species the outbuildings trees
and Boundary vegetation Health potential
habitats for nesting Birds but the
on-site Pond was considered to have a
low substance suitability for great
custom news by the submitted preliminary
ecological assessment so this submitted
ecological assessment considered
mitigation for these areas and identify
that were identified as potential
habitats as well as other biodiversity
enhancements subject to these being
conditioned it conditioned is not
considered that the proposal would have
a detrimental impact upon ecology
so there are a number of mature and TPO
trees within and adjacent to the
application site and as the layout is
not for consideration at the stage is
considered that the development could be
accommodated outside of the route
protection areas for all of these trees
in addition the drain strategy could be
provided subject to conditions requiring
sympathetic construction methods and
further detailing on the construction of
the ponds proposed as part of that
however as per the previous application
the council's agricultural officer is
not content that the TPO Oak Tree on
Eastwood Road could be retained with the
proposed access in place okay if you
could just zoom in on the access there
please
so you may be able to faintly see this
root protection area of the existing oak
tree
which lies there
um there is some decay in this tree and
the proposed access will put pressure on
it through root loss and likely to lead
it to its decline so on this basis there
is an objection to the proposal and that
has been raised
the council's environmental health
officer has raised no objection to the
submitted air quality assessment
concluding that the development would
not cause any new exceedances of the air
quality objectives conditions could be
imposed in regard to matters relating to
renewable energy open space and play
Space foul water drainage and light
pollution were the application being
recommended for approval no objection to
these material considerations are raised
on this basis
the agent has agreed to the heads of
terms for affordable housing Rams and
NHS contributions and therefore no
objection is raised in relation to these
matters and the addendum removed them
from the recommended reasons for refusal
the recommendation has been amended to a
deferment chairman for the reason set
out within the addendum thank you thank
you very much
members before we start the debate I've
got a non-pecuniary interest as I'm
unless it's County councilor
Council uh
we've got public speak here councilor
children Jacobs please thank you
Council Jacobs you have five minutes and
I'll let you know when there's one thank
you thank you madam chairman um
councilors I speak on behalf of the
Israeli Town Council as the chair of the
planning committee in relation to the
aforementioned application
there are a number of concerns that we
have had with this application and I'll
begin with the nature of the proposed
facility and its residents we objected
firstly on the basis of accessibility
with only one access route in and out it
is to boost simply unsustainable and not
fit for purpose on the uh on the point
of sustainability itself
um
I would also like to raise a
particularly sailing point that a member
of the public raised with me this is a
24-hour business housing vulnerable
residents who are quite urgent medical
Medical Care and the property property
will also produce significant clinical
waste which will have to be disposed of
obviously this will cause a significant
strain on the surrounding environments
and housing alongside that
um the road time Council has concerns
not only on accessibility itself but
also regarding public health and noise
pollution
furthermore this application will also
increase the already heavy burden Place
upon the local infrastructure including
public transport and road conditions
alongside a location facing an already
dangerous and hazardous Junction
lastly I raised the very short point of
The Proposal being located on Greenbelt
Land and on over development of the side
those in the flood zone and the impact
on the surrounding environments to
reiterate Raleigh Town Council objected
to this application due to these points
thank you councilors thank you councilor
Jacobs
we have a second speaker who is Mr Paul
Williams is a resident objecting to the
application Mr Williams
good evening
again you'll have five minutes and I'll
advise you when you've had four thank
you
all right can everybody hear me okay
thank you good evening everybody
uh it's only been a short time since
this application was unanimously
rejected by yourselves and I can only
assume that the green belt is still
Green Belt the flood issue has not
changed and the tree has not moved
and all the other numerous issues as
previously raised are still unchanged
I have however notice that the
development access drawing
appears to show the access road has
moved to my to the boundary of my house
it was also raised the the height of the
road
to get rid of the street
gradient access
this brings it within 2.5 meters of my
house wall this is unacceptable
encroachment and undermining my property
further to this the information on the
axis drawing is not to scale misleading
specification and measurements seem to
be contradict also the path around the
oak tree suddenly disappears
further to display
there may be an effect on the two trees
that are on my property tp03 tpo2
by display
while I could go on about many issues of
how it affects me I'd like to bring out
the fact that I think there's a major
issue that seems to be ignored
overlooked probably due to the use of
outdated reports standards and tables
going back to 2009
the axis this is not just an axis it's
an exit as well
to accommodate this the bus stop outside
270 is going to be moved to two five
outside two five four this is just 10
meters from The Junction with Clarence
Road requiring the reroute at number 20
bus
more importantly by placing the bus stop
just 10 meters from this Junction it
will cause problems for vehicles turning
right towards Rayleigh from Clarence
Road this will mean on occasions when
there is a bus stationary these will be
overtaking on the wrong side of the road
turning on the wrong side of the road on
a very blind road which is quite
a dangerous
Road anyway
with the brine bins
with vehicles coming in both directions
we're about in eventually we will have a
head-on collision or a failure to give
Way Type conclusion Collision
this Junction is well known by locals to
be very challenging and dangerous with
numerous accidents including air
ambulance being attending
using the development area to land
furthermore there is currently another
bus stop 10 meters from the proposed
access road towards south end it was
seen ludicrous to me that adding another
major Junction some 30 meters from
another Junction with bus stops 10
meters either side of these
with buses and large Vehicles hoping to
swing out into the oncoming path to
enable them to turn into East Road a
successfully waiting to happen
it would appear to me that the planes
presently for vehicles movement is used
in outdated studies information it's
obvious that with a number of residents
visitors deliveries care workers support
staff aimless's taxis Etc using the only
access points 24 hours a day that the
numbers would far exceed those that have
been presented
therefore are consider it mandatory that
this issue be addressed with a full and
thorough up-to-date Road Safety
investigation that should include
residents for participation
further to this I do believe that uh
I've been led to believe that Aldi Mill
Surgery is not aware of this development
and considering they are at the full
capacity at this current time
it would seem to me that the development
would need to have its own health
facilities one minute
that's it
thank you very much
visiting members
cast across do you need would you like
to say anything on this
councilor Newport
councilman person
no thank you very much right
committee members we've got councilor
Bob Milne and councilor Richard Lamborn
little award do
counselor Lamborn and counselor Mill do
you need to require speak councilor Bob
Milton has the indicated first do you
need to speak as well Council amble
thank you
thank you chairman
um yeah as regards this application uh
really not too much has changed since
the the previous uh application the in
the in the material issues about
planning we've still got the principle
of a green belt
the access for transport and of course
the fact that large buses actually swing
out to the wrong side of the road as
mentioned by the resident there and I
live just down the road from there that
is a dangerous Junction and of course
anglian Waters report or comments uh
page 8.28
paragraph four about the fact that
um
a lack of information about the
potential to have unacceptable risk of
flooding of pollution to the network
and the surface waters strategy flood as
risk assessment
with the planning application is
unacceptable due to no strategy being
included in the planning documents and
anyone who lives around there knows when
there's Heavy Rain that is a big surface
water drainage Channel and what the
effect would be downhill from that
with riparian owners who sometimes are a
little bit lacks in maintenance could be
quite catastrophic so and this issue of
the access so from my point of view I
don't think anything is has changed
since the the previous application just
the number of properties really
and I'm not in favor of it thank you
thank you Council I'm Paul
yes
councilor Mills
um words there The Junction
is very very dangerous so we've actually
been fatalities along that piece of the
road in the past
um and this of course will not help
especially with people running to and
from buses but um that's by the by the
the main
objection that I can see of this is that
it is on Greenbelt and
even even if there were a need for this
sort of care home and later living space
that should be accommodated somewhere
which is not green belt they I think
this Council needs to actually now say
to developers we are not building on
Greenbelt if you want to build there you
have to make sure it's not built
somewhere let's make sure it's not green
belt
so rather than go through the the
offices
um suggestion that we defer this
proposal let this application I propose
that we've moved straight to
um rejection
based on the five
um
five original reasons for
refusal thank you
right so we've got that right
counselor not even done would you like
to come from Katie
thank you chairman
um
so just to clarify kind of on the points
of why we've recommended for deferment
because of the information that we've
had submitted since we haven't had time
to properly consider that and were the
application refused today uh it would
put us in a bit of a difficult position
when it came to appeal because it could
be that that information May kind of
change the consideration it might not
necessarily mean that that reason for
refusal would fall away but it might be
worded slightly differently so we just
have to take into account that that
could possibly kind of play into that
part so we recommended deferment on the
basis that it would allow us for to
competently assess that information and
just to clarify as well if you did move
for refusal
um I would recommend going on the three
reasons for refusal which have
been sustained through the addendum so
that was Greenbelt insufficient
information to do with the flood risk
rather than an absence of a flood risk
assessment because that's now been
submitted so it's just that it's not um
at present we're not able to say there
is no impact and then the third reason
relating to the TPO oak tree thank you
chairman like Council Lamborn you've
excuse me members of the public you
cannot or I'll have to ask no sorry
sorry you can't or otherwise I'll stop
the meeting and ask you to go that's
that's how we have to do it's no good
waving at me you cannot speak I did I
announce this at the beginning of the
meeting
right can you please go
right okay
councilor Lamborn you've put up for
refusal do you is instead of having five
would you go with the officer's
recommendation for the three reasons for
refusal I would go with the three
reasons for me thank you and I also
would like to say that no no I've got to
do that cancer
three
three what can you do it in the mic
please so I am Madam chairman thank you
very much my members
who've got the recommendation for
refusal councilor Lambert would you like
to clarify please
um as I've as I indicated earlier I
think that
um building on Greenbelt trumps
everything if you were to weigh all
these reasons for
um refusal
the far biggest is this is a Greenbelt
site so therefore as a council we should
say no thank you
you've got to do the throw you've got to
do it no no no no you've got sorry
you've got to list out the three that
you're going for
this is what we have to do okay yes
sorry all right thank you
it's in on the addendum if that helps if
you've read the addendum yes yes would
you like them put up on the screen for
you that'd be good thank you yeah Green
Belt flooding and um oak tree right
behind it behind me is that what you
actually
I know it looks like you're doing an eye
test I'm afraid
thank you so the first reason for
refusal relates to the green belt and
then the second is the insufficient
information to do a flood risk rather
than the absence of one and then the
last point is the TPO Oak Tree on
Eastwood Road
you couldn't open that yes
thank you all right members we've got
motion
if this motion goes forward
and you look at other things
would that if we deferred it would you
be able to find other reasons for
refusal to add to these ones if it was
deferred
um so we would be looking at all
information that was submitted if
additional reasons for refusal came up
it wouldn't mean that we couldn't add
them but we do have to be conscious that
this application has been previously
refused so we can't kind of draw upon
reasons that weren't
weren't listed last time so the only
reason that the flood risk issue was has
been brought up again now is because the
policies changed surrounding it if that
hadn't changed it was accepted
previously and we would be in a
difficult position to be able to say now
why that's now not accepted
um so it's not a definite no but it
would just kind of depend on the
circumstance
full refusal we're now gone the motion
through so we've got a seconder I've got
councilor FD counselories councilor
Gadson councilor uh
no
change councilor Foster
okay thank you thank you
thank you chairman
um the older person's need assessment we
haven't done our need assessment on that
so could that be put on as one of the
reasons
sorry as in who hasn't done the needs
assessment well you've had they've done
their was it their own need assessment
yeah so essentially the council has
their own needs assessment which is the
Shema and Cena well the emerging Cena
and they have produced their own needs
assessment to kind of con well yeah
tackle that and approach it from a
different stance so we've gone back to
the Consultants who have prepared the
Shema and Cena and asked their view on
it so it wouldn't be something that
would be an additional reason for
refusal because it's just something that
if
um it would it's just considered as a
very special circumstance in the green
belt so at the moment we don't uh well
the officers report prior to that being
submitted we considered that
because of the information presented to
us it didn't equate to a very special
circumstance we now have to look at that
information and assess whether it
clearly outweighs the harm we could
still see it and agree with their
figures but conclude that it doesn't
equate to a very special circumstance
but we're not even in a position at the
moment that we're able to say yes or no
we don't agree with their figures so
um it kind of comes into the Greenbelt
reason it doesn't form its own reason
for refusal right so if
if we wait to actually get out the
report to agree or not to agree that
could actually strengthen reasons
through for refusal
um in theory yes it would it gives us a
little bit more weight than the position
that we're at the moment where they've
submitted information that we haven't
been able to properly consider okay
thank you
oh sorry councilor Foster thank you
chairman
um I'll take advice whether this is
appropriate or not
and whether it should have been picked
up at the first
submission on page 8.29
4.5 and 4.6
the Essex highways acceptance of the um
proposal is outrageous you should read
the paragraphs it talks about the
removal of the lay-by
creating promoting sustainable transport
to ensure vehicle is not delayed what
they're doing is removing a lay-by to
create traffic jams and
claiming that will encourage sustainable
travel
therefore I would suggest a deferral
anyway they know that that can be
accommodated in a future discussion
excuse me I'm just taking advice from it
can we just stop for myself
I just need to take some advice excuse
me
thank you okay do you would you like to
come back
to the Foster please
um so are you your question is whether
we can reconsider the on carriageway bus
stop is that correct
um it was yes it was about the lay by an
Essex conclusion effectively is to
create extra traffic games in order to
encourage sustainable travel and
therefore they're saying that the
applications acceptable just seems
outrageous to me
um so
I understand where what kind of where
you're coming from with that
um but with Essex County council's
policies they are that we promote
sustainable transport and their concern
is that an additional lay-by would mean
that buses were not prioritized along
Eastwood Road and so
where there's an encourage way bus stop
proposed it means that they are then
prioritized they would I'd also have
concern about
um kind of adding that on because no
objection was taken to that previously
so there was no reason for refusal
relating to that so it we would be in a
difficult position to add that kind of
in the mix now well I said I'd take
advice but it's not the addition of a
low but it's removable
um listening to the three reasons that
have been given to refuse I think that
they're substantial enough that the
other issues don't really need to take
into account at this moment I'm quite
happy with the three reasons that have
been given
we can only do the three as advised by
the yeah thank you uh councilor Stanley
thank you chairman
um
the item that we are looking at
is up there on the board
and that means there are no special
circumstances
in the green belt unless we can prove
that there are special circumstances and
we need to vote on that as considered as
what those three of what we're looking
at
we've done this before with this
application
and there's been no report to us whether
what special circumstances there are for
flooding and the TPO on the tree
so therefore chairman I'd like to take
the vote please thank you
I personally will I'm against voting
against this application I think we
should be deferring it so that we can
get further information so that we can't
say that
we didn't take advice from the officers
if it goes to appeal they're going to
cite the fact that we haven't taken
advice of the officers so therefore I am
against this motion and I will vote
against it on that route okay let's vote
first of all on the motion we've got in
front of us to refuse this application
okay
can I have
votes of a show of hands for refusal
against this application so you want it
refused that's what we're for refusal
okay so can I have a show of hands
please
can I have a show of hands but not the
refusal for not doing the refusal
members
there's
four
eight four the refusal
and five against
so that has carried
right thank you members
um
just let me finish
I agenda items referred from the weekly
list members there are none so I'm
closing the meeting at nine whatever
nine fifty uh eight fifty eight thank
you members for a good meeting